le conflit des pêches premier signe de
détente avant de nouvelles discussions
la pologne dans l'impasse même l'église
recommande la modération aux grévistes
bernard hinault encore un abandon des
ennuis d'estomac dans le tour du
limousin
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir un homme
est mort que vous aimiez beaucoup max
pol fouchet c'est l'un de ceux qui
donnèrent à la télévision presqu'à cdb
une dimension nouvelle et un souffle
nouveau
rappelez vous ces analyses des livres 20
lecture pour tous aux côtés de dégrouper
de l'huma y ait de toute l'équipe
max pol fouchet avait 67 ans il est
décédé des suites d'une congestion
cérébrale à avallon voyageurs pour être
professeur spécialiste de l'histoire de
l'art il habitait vézelay à l'ombre de
la basilique
et cet été encore dans notre série des
100 chef-d'oeuvre il vous avait présenté
vézelay avant qu alain bosquet évoque ce
grand monsieur de la télévision je vous
propose de revoir cette dernière
émission de max pol fouchet
il y a des îles de terre comme il y a
des îles de mer et la colline de vézelay
et l'une d'elles tout entouré par des
collines qui se creuse en valais comme
des vagues qui viennent vers celle du
fonds de l'horizon cette impression ou
marine est renforcée par le grand
vaisseau que porte la colline et qui est
la basilique de la madeleine où l'art
roman se découvre dans toute sa majesté
sa simplicité sa beauté il suffit de
penser aux tympans
ou de regarder certains chapiteau tel
celui ci qui représente un miracle de
saint benoît wasfi le 5 il rencontre un
homme dont le fils vient de mourir à cet
homme lui demande de ressusciter son
fils
et pendant que le saindoux sa prière
l'homme pense à la mort
c'est certainement dans la sculpture
française et dans la sculpture romane
l'une des expressions les plus belles de
l'homme devant la mort
vézelay n'est pas un lieu comme les
autres quelque chose sort de son sol
qu'on ne saurait définir et sa basilique
aussi est très particulière et lully la
gravité du 12e siècle le sourire du 13e
et l'achève bourguignonne elle est un
chant d un plein champ et que l'on soit
croyant ou incroyant ce que l'on reçoit
d'elle c'est un sentiment de certitudes
et c'est bien le sentiment dont nous
avons le plus besoin en ces temps
incertains
il y a chez max paume se fait trente ans
que je le connaissais
il y avait une espèce de course à
l'absolu c'était un homme qui était
généreux qui se donnait qui avait
toujours l'esprit ouvert à tous et
pourtant il y avait un côté tout à fait
mystérieux ses poèmes par exemple où son
roman la rencontre de santa cruz
qu'est-ce que c'était c'était
précisément l'histoire d'un homme
généreux qui fout qu'ils voulaient
partager la lutte d'un peuple qui arrive
qui se donne et finalement ils restent
sur la touche
lorsqu'elle est chose dont il faut pas
se mêler
et je pense à autre chose je pense à
l'action de max paul à la télévision
devant des oeuvres d'art difficiles qui
sont pas cartésienne urvoy tout à fait
pour nous qu'est-ce qui fait est bien
il n'est pas un professeur et ce n'est
pas démagogue
c'est un homme qui parle votre langage
mon langage très simplement pour dire
des choses difficiles il en résulte est
quoi et ça c'est unique au monde et c
max paul c'est que tout le monde
comprenait tout de suite tout le monde
se surpassait avec simplicité
ses obsèques auront lieu lundi à 16
heures devant la basilique de vézelay
jean philippe lecat ministre de la
culture et de la communication a dit
avec max pol fouchet disparaît l'une des
personnalités les plus marquantes des
arts et des lettres
homme de culture et de communication il
avait su mettre son grand talent et sa
sensibilité au service du large public
de la télévision
accomplissant sa tâche avec simplicité
générosité et passion et cédé trois mots
qu'emploieront tous ceux qui l'ont que
europe de l'est ce jusqu ici vous le
savez les événements mme pologne les
grèves qui s'éteint plaidé accord entre
ouvriers gouvernement n'avait pas
suscité de réaction publique tout au
moins de la part de l'urss mais tous les
observateurs ont les yeux fixés sur
cette région du monde et certains
événements peuvent-ils prendre une
résonance particulière tels les mêmes
oeuvres des troupes des pays du pacte de
varsovie c'est à dire les armes et de
l'ensemble des démocraties populaires
or justement les préparatifs pour les
mêmes oeuvres de l'été 1981 ont commencé
en allemagne de l'est
un détachement soviétique du génie qui
fait se déployer dans un seul mouvement
important ce portable ce sont des images
de propagande tourné par la télévision
soviétique
elle nous montre le début des
préparatifs des manoeuvres des 226
division du pacte de varsovie qui se
déroule tous les ans à la fin de l'été
ayez donc pas de rapport direct entre
les événements polonais et ses
déploiements de force même si une
intervention directe du pacte n'est pas
exactement envisageable aujourd'hui en
pologne
les grévistes polonais doivent se
souvenir qu'il fut signé à varsovie le
14 mai 55 qu'il porte le nom de la
capitale et que le texte de ce traité
prévoit l'emploi de la force armée dans
un but
sistance un pays signataire en cas
d'agression armée en europe contre un ou
plusieurs états membres
or le déroulement des crises ambroise
est ce qu slovaque n'est pas permis à
l'urss d'évoquer ces dispositions et l'a
contrainte à recourir pour justifier ses
interventions à une argumentation de
nature idéologique
il est évident qu'un certain nombre de
polonais doivent aujourd'hui réfléchir à
ce que l'on peut appeler une clause de
style qui dans le cas de la bretagne
serait lourde de conséquences alors dans
trois semaines et les forces militaires
des pays de l'otan qui commenceront
leurs manoeuvres sur le territoire de
l'allemagne fédérale
d'abord 48 mille hommes allemands et
américains à partir du 15 septembre puis
les canadiens et les britanniques
viendront s'y ajouter bonhomme informer
tous les signataires des accords
d'helsinki sur la sécurité en europe et
de semblable manoeuvres vont avoir lieu
à peu près au même moment en norvège
il y a quelques jours le numéro un pol
m6 guirec a annulé sa visite aux
chansonniers schmidt
aujourd'hui c'est monsieur schmitt qui
ajourne sa rencontre avec monsieur rené
caire chef du parti et de l'état de
l'allemagne de l'est selon monsieur
balling le porte parole de monsieur
schmitt
les récents événements rendre une telle
rencontre inopportune à l'heure actuelle
et pour en savoir davantage la peine le
correspondant permanent d'antenne de la
bonne
michel meyer pas de doute ce sont les
événements de pologne qui ont contraint
à helmut schmidt a reporté sa rencontre
avec l'allemand de l'est
honecker tout dialogue entre les deux
allemagnes ne peut en effet se concevoir
que dans une situation internationale de
calme relatif
sinon plat et autant helmut schmidt
qu'erich monétaire ne pouvait prendre le
risque de se mettre en porte-à-faux de
se rendre suspect dans leur camp
respectif en forçant la situation
actuelle se repent illustre aussi le
fait que à bonn et bien l'analyse de la
situation polonaise est assez grave est
assez pessimiste on estime en effet que
cette situation ne se réglera pas dit si
tôt et qu'elle aura dans tous les cas
des effets sur les relations entre l'est
et l'ouest
monsieur mes skis ministre américain des
affaires étrangères a exprimé
aujourd'hui sa profonde préoccupation
personnelle
devant la dégradation de la situation en
pologne alors en pologne même les
grévistes du gouvernement s'observe on
attend la réunion du plénum du comité
central la plus haute instance du parti
ouvrier polonais et
annonce de changement à la haute
direction politique les rumeurs vont bon
train pendant ce temps là on dit que
monsieur direct qui a fait un voyage à
moscou
on dit que les grèves pour et septembre
à varsovie et à d'autres points du pays
l'opinion s'interroge elle ne croit pas
à ce qu'on dit assure et signe de vie
vagues études les files d'attentes
s'allongent devant les magasins jean
ping
oui varsovie est aujourd'hui la capitale
des rumeurs le gouvernement dit que les
vivres ne viendront pas manquer
immédiatement des queues se forment
devant les devantures et les clients se
ruent dans les boutiques pour stocker le
ravitaillement ou emplir les coffres de
leur vie le pain la farine le carburant
font en priorité l'objet des achats les
plus importants toutefois le calme
continue de régner en ville dans les
chantiers navals de gdansk coeur du
mouvement
les travailleurs ne recule pas un nouvel
interlocuteur gouvernementale monsieur
yaguine ce qui est arrivé hier fort
d'une réputation d'homme de dialogue
déterminés à ne rien éluder pour aboutir
à un compromis
pourtant les nouvelles de la journée
concours va contredire la perspective
d'un règlement à l'amiable
edward gierek qui aurait effectué
mercredi un voyage éclair à moscou il y
aurait été invité à adopter une attitude
ferme
l'éventualité d'un élargissement de la
grève à la capitale n'est pas écartée
enfin l'emprisonnement de huit autres
membres du corps le comité pour la
liberté n'est pas fait non plus pour
calmer l'inquiéter léman nouveau et
l'attitude de l'église après avoir
publiquement déclaré comprendre la lutte
des travailleurs pour le reste c'est des
droits de l'homme elle leur a demandé
d'être modéré et de ne point s'engager
dans une aventure de caractère qui voilà
qui est d'ailleurs conforme au choix de
la majorité des grévistes qui chaque
matin un prime et publier eux-mêmes
leurs informations touchant le
développement du nous alors après cette
première prise de position officielle de
l'église le maire appelant à la
modération
les grévistes de gdansk tout en leur
exprimant sa compréhension de leur lutte
que dit le pape il ya le pape a célébré
ce matin une messe à l'intention de
l'appareil à castelgandolfo 300 pèlerins
polonais ont pris avec jean paul 2 pour
que le primat de pologne cardinal riche
ch'ti soit un guide pour toutes tes
nation et pour les hommes du
gouvernement afin qu'il conduise le pays
à la paix et à la prospérité d'autant
que l'internationale socialiste réuni à
londres sous la présidence
billy brown ex chancelier d'allemagne a
appelé les responsables polonais je cite
à ne pas céder à la tentation de vouloir
résoudre les difficultés actuelles par
la force ajoutant l'intervention de
l'extérieur n'est utile pour personne
parmi les questions qu'on peut se poser
à propos des grèves dans le maine il y
as est de savoir si des événements
similaires pourraient avoir lieu dans
d'autres démocraties populaires
georges bortoli interview vladimir
borissov fondateur du spot
c'est à dire les syndicats libres
d'union soviétique en lui demandant si
malgré le silence dans ce domaine des
grèves auraient pu se produire en l'urss
rappelons que monsieur borisov expulsés
de la ba réside en france depuis
quelques semaines sans aucun doute on
peut faire grève et nous connaissons pas
mal de grève en urss les grèves ont
commencé presque immédiatement après la
fin de la période stalinienne
il y à des grèves dans les petites
entreprises et aussi dans les grandes et
emploie des milliers ou des dizaines de
milliers de travailleurs mais
habituellement une grève concerne de 50
à 15 cents personnes environ
et ça ce n'est pas gagné et quelques
jours quelques heures le général une
grève en urss est dure pas très
longtemps les autorités font le maximum
d'efforts pour y mettre fin
en général cela va de deux heures à deux
ou trois jours moi je suis à cet hommage
la bastonnade nécessaire suspect on peut
donc faire la grève avec des résultats
règle générale les autorités font toutes
les concessions pour que la greffe
finisse le plus vite possible bien sûr
ces concessions sont temporaires il
arrive qu'elle ne dure que deux ou trois
jours mais qu'on revienne à la situation
précédant mais le plus souvent une grève
en urss se termine par un succès complet
ou partiel heures confie dépêche phase
de détente au moment de réflexion
les marins en grève ont levé
temporairement leur blocus dans
plusieurs ports français et
l'intervention hier soir de la marine se
malafosse n'a pas en plaine et
d'extension du conflit alors que des
discussions sont annoncées dès demain
entre autorités maritimes et pêcheurs le
mouvement paraissent fragmentée en une
série d'actions qui pour
ce temps du moins semble parfois
contradictoires voyons d'abord
l'atmosphère à fos sur mer
l'activité du port aux pétroles de
fos-sur-mer a repris normalement cet
après midi depuis que les remorqueurs et
motopompes de la marine nationale ont
quitté la rade pour le large mais chez
les pêcheurs c'est l'amertume qui prime
et la révolte lendemain de cette
intervention mouvementée de la marine
nationale
cette nuit ici même à l'entrée du port
de fos sur mer les pêcheurs se sentent
floués et impuissants face à la riposte
de la marine et nous avons eu deux sur
leur détermination et leur nombre avec
le renfort venu hier du port de sept
îles sont maintenant deux fois plus
nombreux
quoi qu'il en soit ils n'ont pas obtenu
grand chose lors de la dernière réunion
dans la station avec les autorités
maritimes à la mi-journée et bien sûr il
n'a pas été question du chapitre du
gazole qui est la principale
revendication des pêcheurs il n'est bien
sûr pas possible dans ces conditions
d'envisager une quelconque détente le
blocus pourra reprendre dès ce soir et
les pêcheurs n'exclut pas non plus
d'autres formes de manifestations
violentes
alors justement une dernière information
une douzaine de chalutiers de 7 et de
martigues ont quitté port de bouc à
partir de 18h30 et se dirige vers le
golfe de fos les premiers de ces bateaux
sont arrivés après 19 heures dans les
eaux du port où ils évoluer librement
devant la tour vigie aucune force de la
marine nationale n'était en vue alors
nous allons revenir en arrière nous
allons revenir à hier soir pour voir
comment a eu lieu l'intervention de la
marine nationale décidée par les
pouvoirs publics
hier soir donc 19h45 hier soir à fos sur
mer les deux premiers remorqueur de la
marine nationale se présente suivi peu
après par cet autre bâtiment en
remorqueur dragueur bateaux pompes et
escorteur réaction immédiate des patron
pêcheur se lancer à l'assaut des
bâtiments nationaux otto dix chalutier
de faible tonnage est un chômeur ou un
chat et à la souris aux pressions de
galles spolié sa mère du chalutier qui
avait rejeté l'ultimatum de l'amiral
accary préfet maritime leur intimant
l'ordre d'abandonner dans les dix
minutes toute occupation de rentrée du
port vers 22h unités de la marine et
chalutiers restés sur leur position à
l'entrée du port les patrons pêcheurs
essayer de discuter avec les marins des
bâtiments de la marine nationale
et ces derniers essayer de prendre les
amarres des pétroliers mais voyez
leurs efforts contre elle par les
chalutiers qui s'interposaient entre les
mastodontes et les remorqueurs il a
fallu l'intervention d'un bateau pompe
le louis colet pour réduire la
résistance des pêcheurs libéré les
quatre pétroliers
quant au patron pêcheur de fausses sur
leur faible tonnage il ne pouvait pas
faire grand chose ils avaient espéré des
renforts de 7 en fin d'après midi mais
ceux ci ne sont arrivés que tard dans la
nuit et tout était déjà fini par
endroits sur les côtes de la manche la
situation s'améliore à roscoff les car
ferries ont pu prendre des passagers un
déposer les ports vendéens ont également
été débloquées au havre le blocus est
levé par les marins pêcheurs pour une
durée de 24 heures
geste de bonne volonté en attendant les
négociations de demain les pêcheurs ont
levé ce matin le blocus du port du havre
et de rouen
toutefois à rouen ce sont les dockers
qui ont refusé de décharger un
porte-conteneurs qui la veille avait
forcé l'entrée du chenal
de leur côté les marins pêcheurs
boulonnais ont occupé le port des
aéroglisseurs de calais interdisant tout
trafic levée du blocus au havre pour
autant les pêcheurs n'ont pas regagné
leurs bases et ils apparaissent décidé à
reprendre leur mouvement s'ils
n'obtiennent pas satisfaction à partir
de demain 11 heures
non
vont avoir accès aux camions leuthold
quoi
sans cette trêve nous n'aurions pas eu
accès au cabinet l'auteur si la prod
solution rebouchage le banc du off
comment jugez-vous l'intervention de la
marine nationale
à fos le chimiste orient sont très
propres
comme nous ont fait ou font d'ailleurs
question rezaï matin à 6 heures du matin
dimanche à incendie ou ça vous écoutera
propres
est ce que vous pensez que ça peut
arriver voir non je ne pense pas parce
que lorsqu'une barragiste et uniquement
voulait propre et trop dures qu'elles
résultaient attendez-vous précisément à
injecteur précis on attend le maximum
j'ai des gars à donner des définitions
dans les résultats font la demande est
en principe pour le mazout et le mazout
certainement qu'on n'aura pas gain de
cause puisque le moins cher de la
communauté enfin ils peuvent très bien
faire des concessions sur sur le global
de la pêche pour nos revendications
d'après jeu pour nous l'exportation et
beaucoup de choses et vous pensez que
demain on va vous donner ces assurances
au moins des paroles écrites quoi tout
le temps on a encore des cris on
on est en surproduction war vote de
bateaux sont entrés dans le port
aujourd'hui ce qui représente trois
jours de travail pour les dockers les
touristes britanniques sont arrivés
nombreux dans la journée profitant de
cette trêve de 24 heures en grande
bretagne soit les critiques continuent à
faire les manchettes des journaux
un député conservateur a précisé que
l'entente cordiale entre les deux pays
devient peu cordiales et ne pourra pas
être facilement retrouver la journée de
demain sera importante l'après-midi des
artisans pêcheurs de fécamp est de port
en bessin
ceux là même qui ont provisoirement levé
le blocus du havre rencontre à paris
françois icig directeur général de la
marine marchande puis messieurs les
sikhs verra lundi syndicat des armateurs
pour étudier à nouveau les difficultés
des pêcheurs de boulogne
mais dès demain samedi les autorités
maritimes se réuniront avec les préfets
pour faire le point des doléances région
par région
aujourd'hui la cgt a dit non elle
boycottera ce type de réunion une
interview d'un responsable de la
centrale syndicale
monsieur les gars les propositions du
ministre concernant les commissions
régionales ne sont en fait que qu'une
manoeuvre de diversion et des divisions
des mouvements de grève national des
marins nous considérons que le problème
ne peut se régler au niveau
gouvernemental et au niveau le plus
élevé est tout d'abord au sujet de
l'aide aux carburants il faut absolument
que ces problèmes soient réglés pour
mettre fin au conflit
est ce que vous allez participer lundi à
la réunion de conciliation à boulogne
nous n'avons pas pris de décision
définitive mais en tout état de cause et
compte tenu que le gouvernement n'a pas
changé de position que les armateurs
boulet n'est non plus et en conséquence
de quoi cette commission nationale n'a
pratiquement aucune chance d'aboutir à
un résultat positif
les pêcheurs cfdt cgt du finistère me
disait de pêche ne participeront pas à
la réunion régionale du finistère et
edmond maire secrétaire général de la
cfdt sera reçue lundi matin à
boulogne-sur-mer annonce la fédération
cfdt de transport et de l'équipement
monsieur maire prendra la parole devant
l'assemblée générale des marins pêcheurs
anglais parmi les grands pays maritimes
d'europe il ya la république fédérale
d'allemagne ou dans la
l'immigration par exemple la part du
poisson est souvent plus grande qu'en
france une grève des pêcheurs s'y
déroule en ce moment même
peut-elle se comparer à ce qui se passe
chez nous je vous propose de suivre un
nouveau michel meyer qui connaît très
bien tout ce qui se passe en allemagne
si on compare la longueur des côtes
françaises à celle beaucoup plus réduite
des côtes allemandes
eh bien on s'aperçoit que le secteur des
pêches en allemagne fédérale ne peut pas
être aussi important qu'en france et que
c'est là une donnée de la nature une
donnée de la géographie cela dira ce qui
concerne le phénomène général on assiste
depuis dix ans à une stagnation de la
pêche et même un recul de la pêche en
allemagne et si j'en prends pour preuve
la bible statistiques allemandes
je constate qu'il y a eu 175 une pêche
de l'ordre de 430 4000 tonnes alors
qu'en 78 il avait baissé à 3 194 milles
tonnes soit une perte en quelque sorte
de 40 mille tonnes de poissons bien
entendu cette perte n'exclut bien
entendu pas une rationalisation qui
s'est produit dans le même temps car à
l'heure actuelle et bien
grosso modo on peut dire qu'il y à
moitié moins de bateaux qui pêchent
qu'il y a dix ans et il ya donc eu
rationalisation une rationalisation qui
s'exprime notamment par le fait qu'il y
a dans la pêche de haute mer des unités
tout à fait ultra moderne qui ne ramène
même plus du poisson congelé mais déjà
des poissons en boîte conditionné pour
la consommation bien entendu cet effort
de rationalisation n'a pas pu s'étendre
à d'autres secteurs plus artisanaux de
la pêche allemande c'est le cas de la
pêche côtière et là on retrouve
exactement les mêmes problèmes chez les
pêcheurs ouest allemand que chez les
pêcheurs français avec les mêmes
revendications
ainsi depuis 4-5 jours une grève dans le
schleswig-holstein ou des pêcheurs de
crevettes exige une aide gouvernementale
pour payer leur carburant qui est tout à
fait impayable pour eux à l'heure
actuelle même temps qu'une autre aide
gouvernementale pour passer l'hiver en
quelque sorte lorsqu'ils ne peuvent pas
pêché alors que ça si un conflit à
l'échelle de l'europe
mais en tout cas après le port après le
vin
après le lait après le mouton palais
donc la guerre du poisson ce n'est pas
un conflit tout à fait nouveau déjà tant
de la reine victoria du temps de
l'entente franco correale
franco-britannique est une histoire de
omar avait failli faire capoter cette
entente alors le problème à lequel on
peut le résumer ainsi il ya de moins en
moins de poissons il faut aller le
chercher de plus en plus loin et avec un
gazole qui coûte de plus en plus cher en
1974 le litre de gazole pour les
pêcheurs coûté 13 centimes aujourd'hui
il vaut 1 franc presse alors il ya aussi
beaucoup moins de poissons en 1967 qu'il
y avait environ 5 millions 7 millions de
tonnes de harengs dans la mer du nord
il ya trois ans n'en comptait plus que
250 mille tonnes du hareng ou le voyez
devient un produit de luxe et puis
certains pys protègent leur côté un
petit peu comme si votre voisin vous
avez permis pendant très longtemps de
venir cueillir ses pommes et puis d'un
seul coup vous interdisez l'approché de
ces pommiers bien c'est ce qu'ont fait
notamment l'islande et la norvège alors
on se barre pour pêcher du poisson et on
accuse bruxelles c'est à dire l'europe
de ne pas avoir encore pris les
solutions satisfaisantes alors vous
allez me dire qu'on n'a pas besoin de
l'europe pour aller pêcher et bien si on
a besoin de l'europe notamment de
l'angleterre puisque 60% des poissons
qui sont pêchés par les pêcheurs
européens proviennent des proviennent
des eaux anglaises alors pour le moment
tout le monde on l'a bien vu frappe à la
porte de l'état pour demander des
subventions bien pour demander une
baisse du gazole on connaît les
difficultés des français ont des devoirs
celle des allemands mais les italiens
sont prêts à désarmer la plupart de
leurs bateaux de pêche et les anglais
qui possédait 500 gros navires de de
pêche
il y a cinq ans n'en possède plus que
sont des solutions mais il faut d'abord
trouver un accord avec les anglais
autant vous dire que pour l'instant ils
se font diablement tirer l'oreille vous
en doutez il faut également trouver un
règlement communautaire et celui ci on
le recherche depuis quatre ans il faut
également être plus compétitifs un
espoir également trouver d'autres moyens
d'exploiter la mer et de la repeupler
cela peut être le rôle de l'aquaculture
qui nous est expliqué dans le reportage
que l'on avoir de philippe rapeneau
dans ses rapports avec le monde marin
l'homme à dix siècles de retard
sur la terre ferme l'élevage des animaux
a remplacé la chasse depuis plus de dix
mille ans l'élevage d'animaux et de
végétaux marins s'appelle l'aquaculture
et pour en comprendre la nécessité
il faut d'abord examiner les problèmes
de la pêche traditionnelle
avec 600 mille tonnes par an la france
ne satisfait même pas à ses propres
besoins
le produit de la pêche française est
d'environ 3 milliards de francs et nos
importations atteignent la même balle
première raison la raréfaction du
poisson du à la surexploitation
en cinq ans les prises des pêcheurs
français ont baissé de 12%
conséquence de cet arrêt factions pour
pêcher un kilo de poisson dans le golfe
de gascogne par exemple il a fallu en 15
ans multiplié les besoins en énergie par
trois alors même que le prix du mazout
ne cesse de grimper
ainsi l'industrie de la pêche est
victime de la double incertitude des
prises et des prix pour éviter des
importations encore plus élevé mais
aussi pour préserver l'emploi des 130
mille personnes qui vivent de la pêche
la simple cueillette des richesses de la
mer ne suffit plus il faut qu'une
nouvelle pèse pour beaucoup d'experts la
solution passe par la transformation du
pêcheur traditionnel simple chasseur en
un véritable éleveurs de poissons comme
ici à la coopérative aquacole du tinduff
en rade de brest
pour les huit membres dacquois coop
fondé il ya cinq ans avec l'aide du
centre national pour l'exploitation des
océans
le cne kso cette reconversion
professionnelle a été à la fois
difficile et indispensable et vous
pouvez être certain que la pêche
traditionnelle qui exerce la cueillette
actuellement chief avec un grand intérêt
ce que nous faisons et je pense qu'il le
dise rien quand c'est le moment si quand
ce sera rentable
nous sommes convaincus et nous
travaillons dans ce sens qu'il y aura
sur un nombre d'espèces développement de
donc de l'élevage marins de la culture
mais il ne faut pas créer des illusions
les meules et japonais en me 20 ans pour
arriver à la situation qu'ils
connaissent actuellement ils ont
travaillé dur il faudra que nous aussi
nous travaillons dur aux côtés des ports
incessants de la part des scientifiques
il faut aussi des pionniers prêt à se
lancer dans l'aventuré encore hasardeuse
de l'aquaculture nous en avons rencontré
ici au guilvinec nous petite pêche pêche
côtière surtout va nous envoyer quand
même que ça diminue de plus en plus un
nous caser par exemple et on est obligé
d'avoir peut-être de 30-40 casier de
plus et qu'on avait il ya cinq ans pour
pouvoir gagner notre croûte
alors on s'est dit que ça pouvait quand
même faire un appoint pour nous
sans aucune aide sinon celle du comité
des pêches du guilvinec des marins
pêcheurs et un inventeur ont mis au
point une cage à poissons révolutionner
elle repose par 20 mètres de fond à
l'abri donc des vagues et du vent qui
pourrait endommager la cage est aussi
dans une eau dont la température est
plus stable ce qui est très important
pour le poisson
si le système confiant ses promesses on
pourra multiplier presque à l'infini
le nombre de sites en france où
l'aquaculture cours à s'implanter pour
contrôler l'état des poissons comme pour
les nourrir il suffit de remplir
l'armature d'air comprimé et la cage
remonte en surface
cette expérience du guilvinec
symbolisant fait tout l'aquaculture en
france aujourd'hui
l'entreprise est extrêmement prometteuse
la technologie en est révolutionnaire
mais tout ceci pour les médias reste
purement expérimental à quelques rares
exceptions près la notion de rentabilité
reste du domaine de l'avenir cette
réalité est masquée par les multiples
subventions accordées à la préfecture de
même pour les découvertes scientifiques
sur telle ou telle espèce
on oublie que le travail des chercheurs
est souvent loin d'être immédiatement
applicable sur le terrain à une chaîne
de production important la potion
magique qui fera décoller l'aquaculture
c'est tout simplement du temps il est
certain que l'aquaculture fournira une
part importante de nos ressources
alimentaires
il ne reste qu'une seule question dont
la réponse est aux mains temps des
scientifiques que des professionnels de
la mer quand demain antenne 2010 aura la
forme d'une édition spéciale consacrée à
tous les problèmes de la pêche avec
comme invités entre autres monsieur joël
le theule depuis le putsch militaire du
17 juillet les informations qui viennent
de bolivie sont aussi rares qu'alarmante
ce concept façon certaine c'est que la
junte militaire a supprimé toutes les
libertés démocratiques et que l'armée
entend écraser toute velléité
d'opposition
c'est tout naturellement dans les
centres miniers de la bolivie dont
l'état est ma principale richesse que la
résistance au coup d'état était la plus
forte parmi les mineurs et parmi les
autres payer c'est là aussi que la
répression a été et est encore la plus
brutale
d'après amnesty international
l'organisation humanitaire dont les
informations sont les plus sérieuses 900
habitants de la ville minière de caracol
s 250 km de la base c'est à dire plus
loin de la capitale que la ville de
mille l'unique envers les 6 900
habitants ont disparu
la plupart auraient été assassinés de
façon atroce par l'armée des cadavres
décapités de mineurs auraient été
chargés sur des camions de l'armée et
disent des témoins a bombardé la ville
et tué les habitants qui cherchait à
s'enfuir
ainsi cinq semaines après le coup d'état
du 17 juillet on apprend à travers les
frontières fermées malgré la chape de
plomb qui pèse sur le pays de la
dictature militaire n'a pas fini de
faire couler le sang pour assurer son
pouvoir
d'après le journal l'humanité le député
syndicaliste ciment reyes a été le
premier jour du putsch serait en train
de mourir des suites de ces tortures la
confédération universitaire bolivienne
en exil à paris dénonce l'arrestation et
les tortures infligées à des étudiants
et à des responsables universitaires
aujourd'hui isolé dans le monde y
compris en amérique latine la bolivie
l'entretien de vraiment bons rapports
qu'avec l'argentine et le chili dans les
régimes militaires ont la même origine
que celui de la bolivie l'accident hier
du sous marin soviétique à propulsion
nucléaire à l'aise de l'île japonaise
d'okinawa a pu se produire à l'avant du
bâtiment dans le compartiment des
torpilles estime technicien français ils
pensent que neuf morts c'est beaucoup au
sein de l'équipage 200 femmes et seule
une violente explosion a pu en être la
cause
on savait que commandant du sous marin
russe avait refusé toutes les offres de
secours de lettres m pèse en fait
l'avant du submersible à ep
chez ce qui fait dire aux spécialistes
qui ne doit pas s'agir d'un accident
survenu au réacteur nucléaire car sur un
sous-marin de ce type
ce réacteur est placé à gauche et
bernard hinault a abandonné le tour
cycliste du limousin dans la deuxième
étape au 30e kilomètre il souffrait de
crampes d'estomac
cela pourrait être un incident banal
s'il ne s'agissait pas du meilleur
coureur français
si nous n'étions pas à une semaine du
championnat du monde cycliste qui se
déroule dimanche prochain challenge et
s'il n'y avait déjà pas eu l'abandon de
bernard hinault dans le récent tour de
france avec tous les bruits qu'on avait
fait courir à ce propos et sur lesquels
le grand champion était venu s'expliquer
lui-même un apn 2010 avant-hier d'abord
la course dans la mer
en tête de bout en bout hier à la peine
dès les premiers kilomètres aujourd'hui
tel aura été la surprenante image
laissée par bernard hinault dans ce tour
du limousin 1980 très mal ce matin et
hino lâché dès les premières difficultés
a dû une nouvelle fois se résoudre à
l'abandon après la tendinite les maux
d'estomac
rien ne va plus chez bernard hinault
diront les bonnes langues sans entrer
dans la polémique il faut constater que
le coureur breton traverse une
succession de malheurs depuis le tour
d'italie
plus rien ne lui a réussi reste à savoir
maintenant si cette antero kaulitz et le
nom de son mal ne perturbera pas trop
ces prochains championnats du monde
le teint demain sera ensoleillé en
toutes régions
après la dissipation des brumes
matinales il fera frais un début de
journée puis les températures
deviendront très agréable nous restons
en plein été notre édition est terminée
tout à l'heure après 23 heures
c'est hervé claude qui vous donnera les
dernières informations n'oubliez pas
demain la spéciale antenne de midi sur
la pêche et demain soir vous retrouverez
philippe harrouard bonsoir merci